Michael have you ever had a bad audition
oh yes oh yes just awful
oh my and you know the terrible thing is
you is that stays with you it what we do
is based on confidence anyway you go in
the room and you're confident but when
you just miss it entirely it takes about
three or four more auditions to get your
confidence back up and I've also been
hired off bad auditions you know where I
walked out of the room going Oh Mickey
what did you do what did you what were
you thinking you know and it's the ride
home where you you think of the right
thing to say too late or the right
moment oh now I understand that moment
you know I don't I don't think it's any
different for any of us the guy who's
starting out of the guy who's had
tremendous success and as a star I think
there's a nature of what we do is it
haunts a bit yeah I've had some pretty
bad ones oh I wish I could think of one
I'm sure I've you know in terms of the
specifics of it or block it out I do
remember going in on CSI with the
original CSI and they had a guy who was
a who worked the desk at some you know
ad agency or something I can't remember
what it was but he but he was angry and
they said we really want you to be angry
well you know nobody has to make me
angry they just have to take the layer
off the anger that's already there so
when I gave him the anger I could feel
the room kind of leaning back and Nusa
sad and get that job that didn't go very
well you know and then there the times
you just chew up the furniture and you
can't stop yourself you know
I often will say now because I'm
seasoned enough to do it when they stop
me or when they start to give me
direction before I've had a chance to do
what I've you know what my instincts
have brought me in the room with let me
let me do one let me get this out of my
system so that I can hear you well
enough to adjust but right now I've got
this I gotta get this out and they'll
let me do it you know and most people
lose sight of the fact that it's their
audition we still go in the room
thinking it's the director and producer
and writers audition it doesn't belong
to them belongs to us I can't do
anything about their side of the table I
can make no decisions on their side I
only have one side of the table I can
work but I better own it I better make
sure it's my side of the table so if I
don't like something in the middle of it
or you know I need it did you guys see
that they can we start over you know
what I mean
you do what you have to do and but it's
mine now and so I don't I don't mind
saying okay let me let me get this out
and then I'll I'll try to do whatever
you want because if I try to do what
they want before I've gotten mine out
it's a mess it's a train wreck so what's
your definition though of a bad audition
not just lets aside from not getting the
part of course is it a lack of chemistry
with the person you're reading for is it
somehow the lines were delivered wrong
what what do you consider quote bombing
an audition in your mind well at the
high end of the scale if I can walk out
of the room and do what I intended to do
but also surprise myself that I've had a
really good audition there's something
about that surprise you know that the
that I I was there I was present you
know it happened but on the on the other
end
when you try to force something or I'm
not listening I'm not hearing the other
person has less to do with what they're
reading as it does with my ability to
hear them so I'm not really working off
in if anything that's not a very good
audition because I'm doing everything in
one you know I think it's you go in
there and you have you you you've you've
it's not that you've slotted it but you
have a sense of what your instinct is
about the role and if you go in there
and and and miss that somehow another
tighten up just you miss it then you
leave unsatisfied you just you you you
feel like oh my god
I got I got to get in the car and I've
got to drive 50 miles which is going to
feel like a hundred and fifty miles
because I I've got all this chatter in
my head about what I didn't do and you
know I don't I don't know that that ever
goes away you know I've had those I had
them I because I'm out of the city a lot
I tape a lot now I have to tape and send
in and I'm rarely happy with that
process because I like the room so much
the the feedback is immediate in the
temperature of the room you can see you
you can see it in front of you and I
like that it makes me sharper it raises
the stakes and I can do it for the
camera six times and you know start
looking at it going let's try that again
you know and then you do it 50 times and
you're like maybe we should go back to
the second one we did because that one's
a lot better I don't know that I
mentioned your question I'm sorry but
it's just the sense of being caught and
and not giving what you know you can
give that that's always a frustration
some of these feel really precious and
particularly if you're not auditioning
very much and I think that's the hardest
thing for a young actor
is they only get one audition every you
know two and a half or three months of
four months and you can't help but you
go in with it being too precious you
have to trick yourself that it's really
not and how successful you are or art
with that trick you know it does a lot
to you in that in that moment you know
you've worked in your bedroom your
bathroom you got up in the middle of the
night you woke somebody up you try to
get them back down and then you know you
know the drill you over and over and
over again and you find it and then you
go in and you don't deliver it and
you're just like I want to know the bite
sorry you know that train left the
station done that a lot in my life
you